ignoring the fact that the open house
was one of the worst horror movies I've
ever seen it's abysmal ending has a lot
of people talking perhaps due to the
fact that it is a worse job of spelling
things out than Gareth gates there are a
lot of theories surrounding the new
Netflix original movie in this spoiler
happy video I'll be looking at the four
most likely theories that surround our
unlucky Logan trying to unmask the
killer in a whodunit mystery that never
does any unmasking itself
so without the way let's dive into open
house who was the killer
number four the real estate agents
especially the assistant bar the fact
that the real estate agents are somehow
able to move around the house completely
silent until their job right out pretty
a face contributing as some of the worst
job scares ever put to film there's a
high possibility that the killer could
have been the real estate assistant
first off we all know that real estate
agents are completely ruthless cutthroat
monsters that will slip their
grandmothers throat on a birthday just
again extra half percent in commission
making the character the perfect type of
person to carry out such a brutal brutal
murder secondly they know the house have
access to it and the male is young and
athletic and a bit a bit handsome either
a state agent could have been living in
the house before the arrival of Logan
and I are me since they know that the
property is on the market with their
home up for grabs now they want to
ensure that no one will ever go back
there again and thus killing the
occupants ensures that it also explains
why the killer is seen driving towards
another open house at the end he was
doing his next job over number three The
Invisible Man right hear me out first
yeah it's not the Invisible Man but
throughout the film we hear of Martha's
husband while she is never fully
realized in the movie it is possible
that he is in fact the killer
therefore all talk of him isn't
completely pointless much like this
movie one of the biggest clues is the
fact that Martha states that her has
is dead the first time she meets Naomi
later she corrects this by saying that
he is in fact very alive and strong and
also handsome
could this be referring to the fact that
the man she knew is dead but there's
someone in his place you know like the
same way obi-wan did with Darth Vader
when he was talking to Luke no wonder
Darth Vader was so angry by his ex best
mate was telling the son he was dead I'd
be below enough planets as well but
anyway number two we all know that
plumbers get a bad rep in the movies
whether it's super mario or the very
creepy one in open house if you lay in
pipe you ain't gonna be nice the plumber
is the favorite suspect right now as he
claims to have been in the house often
before he knows how to deal with the
here and finally he was in possession of
the phone that Logan lost although he
said he just found it around the heater
also the size of the killer fits in with
the plumber look look this movie doesn't
clear up anything yeah I'm just
clutching at straws number one Logan
himself well this is definitely the
dumbest theory like think for a second
about how pointless this movie is does
it not make a ton of sense that the
killer is also the protagonist not
really but hear me out the last of the
suspects is Logan it might be likely
that after seeing his father die Logan
had developed a trauma as left him with
some mental disorder disorder of this
night you would explain the strange
things he sees why things change places
and why finally the killer took off his
contact lenses so easily it's because it
was him killing his mother and himself
he was avenging the death of his father
because in his twisted mind they were
both guilty of what happened
look it's a bit difficult explain the
ending of a film that doesn't really
have an ending but hey at least you
didn't waste ninety minutes watching
this movie again this was only like six
ish minutes of your time look it's not
my fault the movies terrible I've tried
my best please show your appreciation
for the fact that I sat through this
three times by hitting that like button
and if you feel an extra generous
subscribe I do videos like this all the
time include in my recent shining fan
Theory analysis and explanation of the
identity of player acts in Molly's game
and there's definitely going to be
something on my channel that you'll owe
thanks again for checking out the video
take care please
you